líderes políticos de todo el mundo así
como el público en general han rendido
sentidos homenajes hoy al príncipe
felipe de edimburgo quien murió a los 99
años en el castillo de windsor han
resaltado especialmente su rol en la
familia real su labor filantrópica pero
especialmente ser el apoyo de isabel
segunda con quien estuvo casado 73 años
y tuvieron cuatro hijos carlos ana
eduardo y andrés ese es el gran rol de
felipe ser el apoyo la columna vertebral
de isabel segunda probablemente nunca
sabremos que tan involucrado estuvo en
los asuntos de estado británicos pero lo
cierto es que estuvo más involucrado que
cualquier otro príncipe consorte desde
que se conoció la noticia de su muerte
el reino unido ha empezado un duelo
nacional que se extenderá hasta un día
después de su funeral las banderas de
todos los edificios públicos se irán a
media asta y las campanas de la variedad
de westminster en el centro de londres
sonarán cada hora durante 99 horas la
reina isabel a jefe
de estado ha suspendido sus labores
oficiales se espera que este sábado se
conozcan detalles de su funeral se sabe
que será más privado que un gran evento
pese a que como principio consorte
tendría derecho a un funeral de estado
él ha comunicado a su familia hace
muchos años que preferiría un evento más
privado y será como les digo militar
dado que felipe fue un piloto muy
exitoso durante la segunda guerra
mundial de la marina británica así que
su corazón está mucho más cerca a las
fuerzas militares y también tendrá que
ser privado dado que todavía en
inglaterra hay restricciones por la
pandemia de más de 30 personas no pueden
reunirse para un funeral de hecho se
cree que la familia real británica
no puede estar completa felipe y burgos
será recordado no sólo por ser el apoyo
del consejero el confidente de isabel
segunda sino también por su carácter
recio disciplinado pragmático y por su
sentido de humor